so störrisch
man merkt man dass die wildtiere setzen
so lange richtet reviertierpfleger rené
walter weiß was die pferde mögen aber
heute lassen sie sogar die möhren links
liegen in den 60er jahren wurde das
letzte uhr wildpferd gefangen und in
einem zoo gebracht
ohne die zoos und ein groß angelegtes
europäisches zuchtprogramm gäbe ist die
art gar nicht mehr den lebensraum
genommen dieser tiere hat die tiere
gejagt und dadurch wurden sie aus
konnten dadurch sind sie im freiland
nicht mehr vorhanden und deswegen fühlen
sich eine andere teil der menschen
verpflichtet das wieder gutzumachen
anführungszeichen
das ist der grund warum zoologische
gärten und auch andere institutionen
sich berufen fühlen oder verpflichtet
fühlen ebensolche bedrohten oder schon
ausgestorbenen tierarten wieder
zurückzufinden die natur das nicht
zurückführen ist schwer sagt
verhaltensbiologin eine berger vor den
toren berlins in der schorfheide ist die
freiheit deswegen zaun begrenzt aber wie
hier drin ist muss weitgehend ohne
menschliches zutun klarkommen
neuankömmlinge tun sich anfangs schwer
damit reserven an fressen für den winter
auf diese idee kommen sie nicht
da wird nicht füttern was machen denn
die anderen hier ach nö
es ist ja nur arbeit dann gehe ich doch
mal ihr hier auf der weide spazieren
also so ernst nehmen die das in dem
ersten jahr nicht aber spätestens im
zweiten nehmen die das dann schon sehr
ernst
die wissenschaftler haben die uhr
wildpferde sehr genau untersucht sie
wollten auch wissen welche
voraussetzungen muss ein preis gefährt
erfüllen damit es in freier wildbahn
überleben kann
mit dieser spezial tränke und
erkennungsmarke konnten sie unter
anderem herausfinden welches tier trinkt
wie oft und wie viel eine waage im boden
muss die gewichtszunahme beim trinken
wer besonders viel wasser braucht sagt
anne berger wurde in der trockenen
ursprungs heimat nicht gut klar kommen
aber auch wenn die hufe nicht ideal
gewachsen sind wäre eine wieder
auswilderung problematisch da wachsen
dann zu einigen zeiten die rufen
wesentlich zu lang und es behindert sie
dann auch wirklich im laufen sind
deutlich langsamer oder stolpern sie
über ihre eigenen beine
und ja und das erschwert natürlich auch
das ganze verhalten dann in der freien
wildbahn
und sie sind natürlich auch er
wolfs futter muss man so sagen in der
steppenlandschaft der mongolei waren die
pferde früher zu hause
jetzt ist es wieder zurück dass tag die
das heilige pferd der mongolen die
wiederansiedlung verlief nicht ohne
schwierigkeiten die winter können hier
sehr hart sein und so starben viele der
pferde in der extremen kälte vor einigen
jahren
inzwischen aber hat sich der bestand
wieder erholt sie haben sich gewöhnt an
die wetter und temperatur extreme an die
wölfe und an das karge land
3.000 chips gibt es inzwischen wieder
weltweit eine berger freut dass alina
das pferd dass die biologische seit 22
jahren kennt wird wahrscheinlich für
immer im reservat in der schorfheide
bleiben aber das eine oder andere pferd
aus der gruppe wird sicher noch in
richtung mongolei auf reisen geschickt
werden
das sind keine leichten momente für anne
berger dem priwall ski pferden hat der
mensch eine zweite chance gegeben
vielleicht können auch andere arten auf
ähnlichem wege überleben